yeah you got to get the oil part you
better spit that out see oh you
swallowed it do you guys have any food
with you he's going to throw up I told
you is he really going to throw up yes
you just had him
eat half of a pepper that's hotter than
the Carolina reap sorry Bill sorry Bill
let's go this is really
tyy oh
my
[Music]
I heard that smokeing had once drove 24
hours through a blizzard and woke up
naked in a field of Chili
Peppers I heard that he has armed guards
around his pepper
Farms he was a drummer and and he was
playing so fast the drums were
smoking he wanted to keep party so he
got into breeding peppers like it would
give him the help boost that he needed
to just continue
partying everything I do I do to
[Music]
extremes yes
Bill ready to get
tortured
hey guys on this week's heat eaters it's
a real special one we're in South
Carolina
somewhere location we cannot disclose
we're visiting the man the myth the
legend smoking at Curry we're going to
visit some of his pepper Fields we're
going to see where the last stab
actually comes from maybe we're going to
get a sneak peek at some future
Peppers Ed that's too much
I'm never scared you know this is part
of the job
[Music]
yeah we're here is that smoking Ed hey
Hester how are you doing how are you oh
I'm having a great day how about you now
I am it is so good nice to meet you nice
to meet you in person yeah do you
remember meeting over the phone with
Noah
hey picked up hey brother how are you
doing smoking Ed hi smoking Ed here's
the special bag the special bag of all
the texures yeah well I smell all the
peppers in the air yeah we're drying
about 4,000 lb of pepper right now in
the dryer same yeah Noah showed me the
first last stb bottle that was ever made
well that's not the first last D bottle
ever made did he lie to me yes he did is
the first case of last stab ever made do
you want to open one up and try
it we we have to do it this is the first
case off the line let me just give you
yeah I think just a teeny teeny bit I
mean you know we're wetting our palette
for today
cheers oh yeah oh yeah it's fun and this
is the way to start a day you know what
doesn't it taste great it tastes really
good actually the last dab that you make
now is a lot hotter I feel like yeah cuz
we started with about 50% pepper okay uh
Tri XX went up to about 80% pepper and
now with this one we're at over 91%
pepper pepper okay and we took pepper to
what to to what's the other vinegar or
pepper and vinegar that's it in this
pepp vinegar this one is like this was
Flavor yeah when I started this I wasn't
looking to start a hot sauce business
hot sauce was just something I made with
the detrius right after what I was
really doing uh okay which was what
studying Peppers breeding them trying to
uh raise capsinoid levels cuz for
medical benefits you know to fight like
cancer and heart disease and things like
that the real reason that all this stuff
started is because a girl wouldn't talk
to me she's my wife now yeah I heard she
liked salsa so I went out to the Garden
I made up some peach mango Sal Sal and I
gave it to her and she's like who made
the
salsa that's so sweet yeah we call it
Linda's PMS each mango salsa but if you
take her salsa you're going to find out
what PMS is okay what's in store today
we'll check out the green houses I'll
take you out and show you the peppers
we'll try some you know and then we'll
go to the factory where we make the last
de and uh then we'll have some food cuz
by then you'll be burning up and you'll
need something I know what I got myself
in too so cool you know I'm ready for it
I'm ready I can't wait to hurt Bill Po
and peppers me and you me and you me and
you sorry Bill we love you we do love
[Music]
you this is where the pollination
happens yeah in the springtime say top
secret after you well it's top secret
except for we're on camera right now and
it's going to go
worldwide these are all different plants
that I've bred over the last couple
seasons and what we're doing in here is
making sure that they're becoming stable
so when you do the first cross you
harvest the pepper from that cross get
the seeds out of it plant it again if
what grows the next year looks like what
you took the seeds out of that's called
the first first generation F1 it takes
anywhere from 8 to 12 generations to
achieve stability to to make a
successful breed yeah right crossbreed
it crossbreed doesn't become a cultivar
until it's 20 years old this is where
the magic happens and sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't right like uh for
pepper X you know even though it's been
around a long long time didn't achieve
stability until until just a couple
Generations ago and we had to get 5
years worth of testing before we could
submit it for anything right pepper X
has achieved stability has been
submitted to Guinness and after a long
uous process it was declared the
Guinness World Record for the hottest
pepper in the world at
2693 million Scoville eat units that's
insane my kids hate it cuz they think I
love the package more than them I'm
going to show you pepper breeding 101
you take a
paintbrush okay and you stick it in the
flow can I do it too yeah and you just
paint around and what you're doing is
picking up poen y okay and then we go
over to this
plant and we pick a
flower and we do the same thing right go
back to the flower you picked over here
then do it again and do it again it is a
very long process one out of every 10
crosses actually works I mean obviously
you're you so you must be working on
something else the next two are going to
be pepper Y and pepper Z I've kind of
trademark most of the alphabet I kind of
think it's cool you know cuz but I think
one should be named after me since I'm
here okay do you really want one named
after you yes I mean yeah here this is
number
eight just take a little
nibble oh yeah oh yeah but it's
delicious good I feel like it has to be
Choy right okay that's what it is that's
what it is number eight you guys don't
forget number eight number eight is Choy
it's Choy it might be the next world
record it might not we'll have to find
out you picked a good one I'm sorry I'm
getting distracted but like literally
these are my babies how are they doing
so yeah this is this is where the magic
starts do you want to go see where it
goes to next of course I can't wait to
hurt
Bill sorry
[Music]
Bill this is my Field of Dreams all the
peppers that I've created that might or
might not turn out to be a next record
and we really don't have a use for them
other than to make pepper Mas that's
really really hot how many varieties of
peppers do you think is in this field
hundreds mostly it's just for me eating
how do you know when a pepper is ready
to pick you're really looking for a
vibrant color oh like
this they're gorgeous yeah aren't they
beautiful they're just so pretty to look
at and that's why I can't give up
because it's like okay this isn't going
to be a real hot pepper it doesn't have
uh what we're looking for that might be
medicinal but it's beautiful I got to
grow it how many peppers are in this
field if I had to guess down here
there's about
900,000 900,000 Peppers yeah that's
insane that will hurt me you want to see
a Reaper look at that Reaper okay so my
I'm so curious how these came to to have
the shape like all the little spiny
little bumps there was a lady from the
island of St Vincent I worked with at
the bank she brought me peppers and
seeds back from St Vincent it was gly
looking and I took uh that pepper and I
bred it with nine others all of them
turned out to be super super hot and and
just ugly looking I mean is that a
pretty pepper no it is not it says don't
eat me do you think that you can taste a
pepper and kind of guess what the scova
level is through years of arduous
research I can tell kind of from the way
I feel how hot the pepper is going to be
because of the amount of dopamine and
endorphin that my body
gets uhoh see inside this
pepper see how much placenta is in there
what does that mean this is pepper why
pepper why the tissue around the skin is
also white mhm
uh that's what produces caps yeah okay
so is pepper y supposed to be hotter
than Pepper x uh my attorneys don't want
me to say anything about that okay we're
not saying anything about it my wife
recommended this cuz when when Linda
tries a pepper she she knows not to
trust me okay she takes her fork and she
just touches it and then she touches
that to her tongue cuz she knows I'm an
idiot you're good with that wow that's
kind of crazy yeah that's very crazy uh
that's insane insane yeah and this isn't
even the oh my God it barely touched the
spoon barely touched it too yeah wow wow
is right freaking powerful see this is
just this is a hit a dope for me you
know wow so most of the peppers in here
are like that okay that's amazing it's a
beautiful
thing oo that look look I'm getting
high I'm not going to be able to really
tell the difference between a Carolina
Reaper and Apollo and pepper X cuz
they're all crazy hot on the reaper
because I bred it with that one pepper
the first thing you taste is sweet when
you eat the X pepper it's just a full
punch the first and then the ride is is
devastating I literally felt like my
eyeballs were going to come out I'm
sorry there's one pepper behind you that
is just drawing my attention see that
pick
it I have been looking at that pepper
the whole time we've been talking look
at that it's like so sharp guess what
that is pepper ax that's it now you just
had the other one do you want to do a a
spoon test on this one yeah let's do it
he very very oily look at that yeah oh
my God just touch
don't oh my
God so tell me can you tell the
difference between
heat Ed that's too much how could
someone eat that only a few of us have
I'm trying to honor God in everything I
do and the only time I curse is when I
eat peppers it's [__] brutal that's
the only way to describe it I can't
believe it it's like the one area that I
put the spoon to my tongue It Feels So
raw like it's going to come off honestly
it feels like raw skin you want to taste
the peach Reaper right now see if you
can taste it yeah smell
again okay see now that smells sweet
right all right now see Reapers again
have all that membrane that produces oil
but it has a much different flavor
profile you get that sweetness before
the heat comes on I just love the way
they
smell yeah these are gorgeous like super
floral mhm no that's really
hot I was talking about the smell but
now that ah yeah but it's a different
see before when you tried the other one
you were like boom right away this one
you started talking slower burn and you
were like yeah ah so it's a different
type of burn burn uh because it's yeah
sorry oh my God these are the best
tasting peppers in the world as far as
I'm concerned can I pick one for him to
try oh what yeah sure what is that one
it's beautiful it's beautiful it looks
like
me which one is that
wow
w
we but it's you didn't even eat the
membrane though you ate the outer part
yeah it's the skin yeah he like the
outside Park where there's no oils in it
many years of training where should I
bite then just bite it in half you can
spit it out it's okay to spit yeah you
got to get the oil
part yeah that's a better bite now throw
that into the field thank you
pepper you better spit that out see oh
you swallowed it I did do you guys have
any food with you uh
yeah he has
some I'll be okay okay he might get sick
in a little bit this is a many years of
training you know all those oh my
God that's what I said you might get
sick no because I like I yeah pretty
soon he's going to be on his knees sorry
Bill not yeah hey it's okay you
know do you think was that one
hot someone's got to take this
camera uh-oh need to take a little
break oh that's that's bad yeah that's
bad he's going to throw up I told you is
he really going to throw up yes you just
had him
eat half of a pepper that's hotter than
the Carolina reap need some food
okay good yeah sorry B it's okay you
doing okay yeah I'm good wait till later
damn I didn't know it was that it was
going to be like that so what does it
take to secure these fields well you
know people have tried to steal Peppers
so there's security cameras everywhere
we've actually hired security to guard
fields we have hundreds of employees
that are always around every single
plant in this field um takes years and
years and years to bre took a decade to
get to this point you know and then
someone's going to come in and go oh
look what I did one guy claimed to have
the pepper sent seeds out overseas uh
the US Marshal Service got involved the
local police got involved that's insane
uh who knew the post office has its own
police force and violated so many laws
it's unbelievable there's only one thing
to do I know you can blur it out okay Ed
what's next what are we doing well I
think I think we should uh head up to
the last dab Factory can't wait
yeah
[Music]
here we are yeah here's the factory and
uh first thing I got to do is take you
to get a lab coat on yeah I don't want
any contact happening lab coats lab
coats so necessary huh yep are you going
to wear one nah nah nah it doesn't
affect me that way definition of thick
skin huh that's the definition of thick
skin oh my God on it's in intoxicating
literally oh my
[Music]
gosh peppers come in from the field in
totes we're using cayen today the first
step is to go into the wash or insort so
it goes into this big machine that dumps
them and it agitates them to get rid of
any detrius that might be still in there
and it goes up a belt and it gets washed
and then it drops down into the fenc m
and then we're washing them again and
picking out anything we see and it gets
ground into this pul and that pul each
one of those weighs about 800 lb when
they're done and they wheel that in and
there's a machine that dumps that back
down into the kettle we have a little
bit of vinegar to bring it to the right
pH and then we bring it up to
[Music]
temperature and we bucket it into 5 gon
buckets once we have buckets of mash
then we can make hot sauce we get the
mash into the kitchen today we're making
the classic so it has very minimal
ingredients so we mix up those
ingredients with vinegar and then the
mash and the ingredients get into the
kettle and we heat it up very slowly and
that way all the flavors get to M
together it pumps out of the kettles
into the bottling
machine once the bottle's filled it goes
into a line and it goes
around and then the label gets slapped
on it and as the label gets slapped on
it the bottle starts
spinning and then it goes to a machine
that drops down the shrink
WRA and then it goes through the heat
tunnel
and the heat tunnel does the shrink rat
and make sure everything looks good and
as it comes out we have another guy make
sure the bottle's perfect and he's
stuffing cases handing them over to
another one who's taping cases to make
sure it's safe and then we stack them on
the
pallets that's the whole process for
making hot
sauce oh my God oh my God I actually
could not breathe it there yeah it's
kind of it's kind of nasty in there that
was crazy yeah but how do you handle
that just get used to it you know uh
some people never get used to it I just
I don't even smell it I think what we're
going to do we're going to surprise
Everybody by having some barbecue I have
a little sit down family meal yeah and
if they talk any crap about me they're
[Music]
fired hey everyone this is Esther hey
guys hello let me introduce you to my
wife
yes hey baby hi smoking head how are you
a this is how are you nice to meet you
I've been hearing about you all day so
it's finally nice to put a face up to
the name don't believe everything you
hear one thing people don't know about
Ed he's one of the most generous caring
people in the world he'd give his shirt
off his back if he needed it his name is
Brandon he calls my wife mom yeah that's
Mom smoking Ed is obsessed with
Christmas like literally obsessed he has
a Christmas tree up in our store year
round that we decorate for every holiday
I mean it's beautiful look at that yeah
now see this is something we're braiding
out because look there's inside walls so
there's more of that area to produce
caps he's very open that he's in
recovery from addiction but what you may
not know his new addiction is Pokemon he
is a Pokemon fi and thank you so much
for this amazing day first of all it was
eye openening and I learned so much
honestly the honor is all ours we
appreciate you coming down and us
getting to share what our passion is and
seeing where everything comes it's an
honor a lot of people don't know about
my dad he he really funny and makes a
lot of people laugh think that we should
do like a little last up tears the only
for you es only for you only for me when
Ed eats stuff that you guys think he's
not burning up it's because he does MO
breed watch his lips when he
get uhoh oh really I'm issuing a
challenge are you sure that's kind of
that's not what I'm I mean that's kind
of a lot I'm
scared Cheers Cheers Che
yours so hot
but so good they should not be using
chicken on the show they should be using
brisket I got something special for we
have some special for Bill oh my God
that it looks awful that looks like
vinar turn it upside down it's not
smelly
mhm all right who's grabbing the camera
it's Bill's turn maybe you should wait
till you get
food what did
you
it's tasty yeah see everybody thinks I'm
going to hurt people oh no well because
you
do that's what you do stay all day
breathing you want a spoonful of banana
PD that's a secret oh man that's is it
spicy
banana not it's me handed it to you not
it today's
crazy oh that's actually that helps a
lot this is an
antidote
no wow okay well if you stick out your
tongue there still a black mark over
[Music]
you hey guys it's Esther from heat
eaters thanks for watching please like
And subscribe and for more episodes
click here